two local supermarket Giants announcing
a proposed merger today we're talking
about Kroger which owns Smith's it's set
to buy Albertsons in a multi-billion
dollar deal and right now there are 38
Smiths and 21 Albertsons or Vaughn
stores all across the valley so what
does that mean for us locally Sasha
Loftus explains
Shoppers we spoke with here at
Albertsons and at Smith's are split on
this decision some think it could be a
good thing While others are worried it
could make prices go even higher as we
already deal with inflation here locally
every month it's a little bit more and
more keeping up with Rising grocery
prices instead of buying K-Cup coffees I
buy instant coffee you just you got to
adjust Shoppers in southern Nevada say
it's been a struggle to make ends meet
as inflation and supply chain issues
lead to bigger bills well you're looking
at 125 every time you shop now more
changes could be coming Kroger the
company that owns Smith's announced a
potential merger Friday buying
Albertson's stock in an estimated
24.6 billion dollar deal whenever they
emerges and Acquisitions with large
corporations you're always concerned
about the price economic experts
Shondell Newsome says this might leave
room for a monopoly sometimes what
happens is
um prices uh go through the roof because
of lack of competition but others say
they have to hope for the best trying to
raise two kids and the prices are up you
know it costs money
you know not this cheap nowadays and
look forward to any new opportunities
it'll help trust me as for locations
here like Tropicana and Jones there's an
Albertsons in this parking lot and a
Smith's right across the street now if
this merger were to happen it looks like
the company could sell off some of these
stores to prevent overlap reporting near
Tropicana and Jones tonight social
Loftus 8 News Now